welcome everyone to the Allen P Kirby
jr. center for constitutional studies
and citizenship and it's also the
location of Hillsdale and DC's newly
launched Steve and Amy Van Andel
Graduate School of Government my name is
dr. Matthew Mian I am the director of
academic programs here at the Kirby
Center and I teach both the
undergraduates who come visit from the
main campus in Hillsdale Michigan and
also in the grad school as well as other
more bureaucratic duties but I also get
the privilege of conducting some of
these book interviews so before I go any
further I want to introduce Richard K
Vetter he's a senior fellow at the
independent Institute and distinguished
emeritus professor of economics at Ohio
University and I just met a number of
his students who came all the way out
from there tonight so it's a great honor
for a teacher to have loyal students who
will travel that's great
he has been senior economist at the US
Joint Economic Committee and visiting
fellow at the Center for the Study of
American business Washington University
in my hometown st. Louis besides his
most recent book dr. Vetter is also the
author of going broke by degree why
college costs too much his articles have
appeared in numerous scholarly journals
The Wall Street Journal Christian
Science Monitor National Review
Washington Times and investor's business
daily and relevant to our purpose
tonight and perhaps also his most
impressive accolade
professor Vetter has been a teacher for
55 years
Oh 54 years alive here's something I so
I lose count at my age I can't count
very well but it's something like that
yes why is an experience he also has
deep roots in Illinois that makes him a
Midwestern Westerner thereby earning him
the title to be held hereafter in
perpetuity of good people yes that's
st. Louis my wife's from Springfield
Illinois and for you Gen Xers in the
crowd I regret to inform you that he is
I believe no relation to Eddie Vedder
lead absolutely not never met the guy
even though Eddie Vetter Eddie Vetter is
from Evanston Illinois but school that I
attended actually in that town and I
will try to use some references to
lyrics to Pearl Jam throughout the
interview but I'd like to thank you dr.
Vetter for writing this book restoring
the promise higher education in America
the Kirby Center here in DC on Hillsdale
College in general we care a lot about
trying to build up and enrich
constitutional self-government in our
country and I was just teaching the grad
program the other day we were going
through Aristotle's politics where an
Aristotle just sort of drops this bomb
oh by the way if you actually care about
politics statesmanship and leadership
your fundamental concern would obviously
be the education that perpetuates the
regime it's just sort of a startling
just drop and you've applied much of
your career and now this book in
particularly taking up higher education
we're future educators and future
leaders in pretty much all fields are
formed and informed that is to say I'm
very happy to have this discussion with
you especially about this subject
because it's fundamental to our concerns
of the common good and to the entire
country into self-government so without
any further ado and throat clearing I
just want to sort of ask you to sort of
give us the bird's eye view the elevator
pitch
what is restoring the promise higher
education in America what's the promise
well I don't know what the promise is
because I didn't pick the title some
marketing guru picked the title and
darned if I know what the promise is
however having said that I think the
promise relates to the fact that higher
education is to serve the common good
and is to serve a society in a very
positive way and to some extent it does
that but in some extent it fails and so
how can we make it come closer to the
ideal and I suspect the problem at
restoring the promise refer refers to
that and but the reason I wrote the book
is that there are several problems with
higher education in America we know all
of the we know all of you know what they
are I'll use my fingers here we don't
have PowerPoint here which is great I'm
grateful for that by the way I don't
know I shared a bike I hate hate
PowerPoint I'll use what I call I hope
this doesn't offend anyone West Virginia
Power Point I'll use my fingers thing he
does not speak for the college Hillsdale
College has already disowned you dr.
Vetter do you want to leave now
no first college is too expensive I mean
everyone agrees with that there isn't a
person in America who seriously
disagrees with that some people
apologize for higher ed will say it's
still a good bargain you're still
getting your money's worth but the
reality is the costs and higher ed
however measure have risen vastly faster
than the rate of inflation etc for many
many years and I can go into that in a
minute but let's get just do the
shortened dirty version of this now the
second thing is happen and this is more
scandalous and I hesitate to say this in
front of my own students but let's face
it people aren't learning as much as
they used to and they're not learning
enough and maybe they're learning the
wrong things and there's all sorts of
empirical evidence
and some of us a little snippy a little
limited because it's funny in higher ed
we we are in the knowledge business we
like to report every little facet of
every human endeavor but the one thing
we're not very we're a little neglectful
on is do we measure whether our kids are
learning anything are they doing better
now than than they would do a generation
ago do seniors know more than freshmen
do the graduates of Hillsdale College
learn more in their four years at
Hillsdale then the graduate of Yale
there's a Yale student in the audience
I'll pick on Yale and my guess is the
answer is yes but I can't prove it
so there's that issue and with that is
the whole issue of of suppression of
ideas the lack of intellectual diversity
and universities and so forth so that's
the second area of problems I actually
somewhere I think I might have a great
quote from a lot of people Thomas Edison
who in 1921 told the New York Times that
you know I do
look I hire a lot of college graduates
and I think they're abysmal a ignorant
that was a 1921 we fast forward a
hundred years and I think they know less
than the people in 1921 news so where
are we the third problem and then I'll
keep quiet is are the students today who
are spending twenty five fifty a hundred
thousand two hundred thousand dollars
going to college and some of them go to
yuppie private preparatory schools such
as one that you teach at I should I'm
picking on you but it's the hobby
lobby's a world of yuppies and do they
get good jobs after they graduate some
of them do some of them do very well my
students are all uniformly brilliant and
they're all going to end up making tons
of money someday or if not tons of money
tons of said
faction oh that's not true
oh you just look at them you can see but
they're gonna do reasonably well but the
reality is a lot of kids go to college
today and they don't graduate not at
Hillsdale well 90 some percent of the
kids graduate but at schools around the
country 40 percent of the kids who enter
college do not have degrees six years
later not four years later not five
years later six years later they don't
have college degrees so you lose 40
percent and then many of the others are
who do graduate are living in their
parents basement so there's three
problems and there are others we can
talk about but I've talked long enough
sorry no yeah the I wonder if we just
take each of these one at a time for a
little while okay and and and when we do
I prove what I what I what I most want
to know is sort of who do I get to blame
right so Google who is it the higher
Ed's problem is it is it a societal
change is it a governmental change sure
but with regard to cost who do we where
do we point the finger to get well I'm
the problem
that's it's a good question let I assign
a large percentage of the blame to
horrors of Horrors the federal
government the government of the United
States of America and to think that I'm
saying this within a stone's throw or a
long stone rebar three blocks four
blocks at a younger age I could have
thrown a stone and hit the US Capitol
from here but again he does not speak to
college
[Laughter]
a large part of the problem is a federal
problem and and I hear it's just as
simple as can be the federal government
made a nice decision as seemingly
seemingly it wasn't a nice decision 50
years ago we want to help poor we want
to increase access to higher ed we want
to help low income people go to college
it sounds like a nice thing well 50
years ago 10 percent of college recent
college graduates came from the bottom
quarter of the income distribution from
the let's call them poor people 10% no
or 12% sorry 12% I shouldn't have had
that glass of wine before I talked now
it's down to 10 it's down to 10 it's
less today higher ed is still largely
for middle-class and upper-class people
not entirely but still largely but we
put this in to help poor people what did
it do what did it do what did the
colleges do when they said who kids can
borrow money and up to the cost of
attendance and so what did the colleges
do they started raising their fees
aggressively except and and I'm really
serious about this except Hillsdale
College and a few others a very very
very very few others so here's a little
factoid before 1978 going back to 1840 a
hundred and thirty-eight years of
American history the price of college
rose 1% a year more than the overall
inflation rate and that might be
explained by the some of the arguments
that people use today that it's a
service industry it's hard to substitute
professors in a classroom with machines
those kind of arguments and a gentleman
in the audience is shaking is no it had
no and he's right about
that too but for the moment let's just
kind of by that argument that might
explain a little because as the economy
of the whole nation got better and
richer we had to pay professors more and
even though they weren't teaching any
more students than before we still had
to pay more so per student costs rose a
little maybe that would explain the 1%
since 1978 fees have gone up 3% a year
not one percent a year 3 percent a year
is there no big deal do a compounding 3%
a year compounded doubles every 24 years
over a course of a half less than a half
a century quadruples tuition fees have
tripled since the adjusting for
inflation since the late 70s a large
part of that is due to the government
involvement Bill Bennett said it
perfectly he was a former Secretary of
Education by the way a philosophy
graduate of Williams College trained in
classical training bill bennett said
this in 1978 and a New York Times op-ed
and it's true today so I mean no great
revelation so the student loan program
and the federal government generally and
I could I could elaborate on this that I
can tell you rich stories about the
Department of Education and its creation
let me tell one real quick this is just
too good to pass up in 1976 Jimmy Carter
was elected president of the United
States he promised a Department of
Education why did he promise apartment
of Education was anyone clamoring for
Department of Education yes the National
Education Association NEA the teachers
unions he didn't do anything for two
years Jimmy's a little slow sometimes
nice man by the way I met Jimmy Carter
my wife and I had drinks in a wood
Jimmy Carter we try to eat dinner with
all kinds of different people and Jimmy
was one of them in 79 Jimmy Carter
Hamilton Jordan his chief of staff said
Jimmy President Carter probably
President Carter you have to deliver on
a Department of Education and Carter
said why
well an EI wants it okay what was the
reaction of the general public when it
Carter said I'm going for the department
what did the Washington Post say it's a
dumb idea
the wire she could boost what did the
New York Times say we're against it the
New York Times was against it what did
the most respected intellectual of the
era on the progressive side say Daniel
Patrick Monahan it's a dumb idea it
passed in the House of Representatives
in the Education Committee by three
votes barely made it through barely made
it through Congress but they approved it
anyway narrowly skits got through and
became law
what's the Department done since is
higher ed better off than it was 50
years ago is public education K through
12 education better off than it was 50
years ago are we as a nation have
progressed in this for decades
I look at the data I look at the
evidence and by the way I I've been on a
public school board elected public
official on public school boards I at
the K through 12 level I looked at it on
throughout the whole thing I don't see
an iota of improvement and I see in some
ways we're worse off we're paying more
we're getting less and were being
directed by bureaucrats and educates who
live here in Washington DC when
sometimes
people out in the boondocks of wherever
the middle part of flyover country that
I'm from flyover country I'm profess I'm
not quite as smart as some of you people
live on the east coast where knowledge
is much greater or on the west coast
where now you're the writer I'm part of
the other than where the planes dumb
middle part of the country but some of
those people in the dumb middle part of
the country aren't quite as dumb as you
make it out to be and you know I think
we do it all right then
anyway I'm sorry oh I'm talking too much
but it's it's it's it's a question I
have that with regard to cost so the the
the occasion for this ramp up this
exponential ramp up is the federally
backed loans right yes but don't we
still fault higher ed for sort of
greedily grabbing at it
oh well battling all these students with
well the higher ed of course grabbed at
it and and what about the families no
the families be damned well more or less
and you know I will say there are
exceptions we're in the temple of
exceptions here at Hillsdale but you
know gross city college there's some
other colleges that have done similar
things and have said just say no to the
federal program so the federal programs
have have been the basis for it a lot of
colleges do it but people are who run
colleges they're decent people they're
not all mean people they don't all beat
their wives or whatever you know they're
morally they like to say they're a
little bit better than the rest of that
I don't know whether better or worse but
they're normal people and they're
tempted they can say hey we can raise
our fees six percent of your instead of
four percent here and if we do that we
can lower teaching loads for the faculty
if we do that we can hire 42 more
administrators and we can get these
people who are yelling and screaming
about diversity inclusion who are giving
us a hard time we can hire 42 more
diversity coordinators how many
diversity coordinators are there at the
University of Michigan how many last I
counted 93 93 27 of them making more
than a hundred thousand a year you're
shocked I'm not I live in higher ed I
see it all the time
and I'm not picking just on that field
you do the same thing with public
relations specialists you do the same
thing with athletic programs you do the
same thing across the board and it is an
outrage my university which is a typical
state university in the mid 70s had two
faculty members for every one
administrator now we have for every two
faculty members two and a half
administrators Mura ministers and
faculty in fact I proposed of the
president University why don't you give
every faculty member their own
administrator that reorganize the
university will give every faculty
member sort of like a valet
administrative valet and I think it'd be
a cool idea sorry I'm yeah that's good
the the well so is the is the proposed
solution for the federal loan program do
what hills dales done get off of the
sort of crystal meth
that's sort of driving everything yeah
or or are you proposing get rid of the
legislation altogether that it has no
public utility then well I would love to
get rid of the legislation I really
would but I used to work for the gang of
535 that is across the street roughly
that is to say the US Commerce I've
worked there I know those people
I've lived with those people have I said
enough
they're not gonna do it and I don't
blame them I mean from a job security
point of view most Americans think it's
a cool program and you don't want to get
rid of something that's cool and so the
ad what is the solution well one group
of Americans this and I don't want to
tie it specifically to political parties
but in this current environment we see
it especially among progressive
Democrats the Lizabeth Warren Bernie
Sanders but now pretty much all of them
say let's just forgive the debt why
don't we just say forgive the debt what
the heck we just let them what's another
trillion dollars or two trillion you
know we're running by the way every day
three billion dollars deficit the
federal government every day
do the math 125 million an hour two
million a minute do the math further
30-some thousand a second and the time
it took me to say that we ran up another
half million dollars of debt and here we
are in this environment of total
political irresponsibility and both
parties Republican Democrat vegetarian
Presbyterian whatever political party
you belong to and we're talking about
forgiving a trillion dollars worth of
death a trillion and a half dollars
we're gonna tell people who've worked
hard their lives paying off that debt
we're gonna say yo you were suckers
you were you were suckers haha you
actually believed the government didn't
you tough but are the other people who
bought second homes or took out big more
you just and took trips to Europe and so
forth didn't pay down their debt you
don't know anymore
free at last I think that's shameful
what do you think that does
to future obligations what do you think
it tells Americans in terms of meeting
their obligation what does it say about
meeting the sanctity of contracts what
does it say about the rule of law it is
horrible it's horrible horrible horrible
I think I made that clear didn't I
so be quiet so I I wonder I mean you
have this other question that sort of
the problem of the content right the
price the family's willingness to take
on dead isn't it it's right it's an
evaluation of the relative worth of a
degree yeah that's right right and I
wonder if the problem would be
alleviated somewhat if the American
people families parents high school
students were better at appraising the
relative value that is true there's one
thing I've been condemning the
government I suppose I should be at
least halfway nice to the government for
maybe seven or eight seconds today today
the federal government announced that
they in their college scorecard which is
a document where you can download
information college by college they
report the average earnings alleged
average earnings of graduates by college
and now they are giving you the data
even by major so you could look at you
can't look at Hillsdale because
Hillsdale is verboten they're out of the
system Hillsdale is not in because they
refuse to kowtow to the federal
government but most schools you can look
for example at my university I looked up
economics majors and I learned that the
average earnings after graduation was
thirty thousand dollars and I said my
gosh that strikes me as awfully low well
attorney and I learned that the average
debt of students is twenty-five thousand
upon graduation that statistic is
probably fairly close to accurate so
that's a nice kind of statistic and you
could do this for
any college anywhere the the young lady
here for who's sitting in the fourth row
from Yale but who is still looking for a
job that's probably 50 to 70 mm at Yale
and their debt is less because Yale
drops money out of airplanes over their
students because they got a twenty five
thirty billion dollar endowment so but
you get that statistic and that's kind
of good information so the federal
government has the potential providing
information turns out there's only 47
Ohio University economics graduates in
the sample when there are hundreds and
thousands of these only 47 made the
sample and then it turns out oh you
don't get in the sample unless you had
borrowed money from the federal
government to begin with well there are
a lot of people who don't borrow money
from the federal government so the data
is vastly distorted just horrendously
distorted but it's a tempting the
attempt is a good one
and I've talked to secretary DeVos who I
think is an honorable person from the
state of Michigan I see the Van Andel
name on this very building uh Associates
of the DeVos family from Grand Rapids
Michigan wonderful family wonderful
people but I love Betsy DeVos but I wish
they would close her operation down and
maybe it's time to elect the Georgetown
University ROTC have a bombing practice
over Maryland Avenue in Washington where
the Department of Education is located
anyway he does not speak for the college
yes so barring air strikes the last time
I heard anyone credibly
a candidate credibly called for the
destruction of the Department of Ed was
Bob Dole well yeah it was part of his
loud platform what's the big the big
push how old was Bob Dole now 140 243
yeah
um one of the things I found very
interesting about your your-your-your
book is it's sort of you deeply
ensconced in the economics of higher ed
who's paying for what right where's the
government funding what state schools
versus the Ivy League or the the the
plucky liberal arts college or or the
Citadel of Reason that is Hillsdale like
where are these who's paying for what
well that's a good question and I can't
answer the question definitively but I
would say that there are a lot of people
who are seeking educational attainment
of some sort we're really getting
relatively little from the federal
government what about the person who
graduates from high school who is not
academically terribly interested in
academic affairs and not very adept but
it's pretty good with their his hands or
her hands and wants to work as a welder
or a plumber but it's going to take a
year or two of training to make that
happen
or take this brainy very brainy high IQ
kid who's good at coding whatever coding
is something to do vaguely with
computers I'm told and very good and
they can go to a coding Academy and in
six months if they're good learn a lot
and get a job paying 60 or 70 or 80
thousand a year and the whole cost of
the coding Academy experience is fifteen
or twenty thousand those people are
getting almost nothing from the federal
government almost nothing the kids who
go and I'm picking on Yale and yells a
nice school it some would say it's the
best in the Ivy League's and
I sort of agree I kind of like Yale it's
got its got that yuppie look of Harry
Potter look about it that's very nice I
I always thought Harry Potter was one of
the most positive recent contributions
to Western civilization and why are we
giving more to the kids to go to Yale
who come from relatively well-to-do
families to begin with and not only what
we give to the kids how do we give well
that's right how do we give to you how I
did a study once comparing Princeton
University I'll the the gal from Yale is
having heartburn back there so I will
now pick on Princeton for a minute if I
may here's two schools tale of two
schools how far apart of the 11 miles
one of them is called Princeton
University the other one until recently
was called Trenton State University it
is now called college of new jersey
which is the original name of Princeton
a brilliant marketing move on their part
by the way here are these two colleges
we call Princeton a private school we
call the College of New Jersey a public
school how much money does the public
school College in New Jersey get
directly or indirectly direct government
subsidies gifts grants to students
research whatever may be three four or
five thousand dollars per student state
of New Jersey adds a couple thousand
dollars maybe six seven thousand let's
exaggerate what does Princeton get
Princeton gets the Vantage's of tax
deductions
against income which fund a ton of
things donations to buildings of for
example there's Whitman college at
Princeton any of you been to Princeton
Whitman College at Princeton lovely
lovely
named after meg Whitman a minor figure
in American public finance a Bay Fame
cetera cetera H whatever else she did
she gave this little college was bill a
little dorm for the kids at Princeton
caught 350 kids lived there
Scott stained glass windows ceiling in
the dining room is 34 feet high
I had it measured ah I talked to people
and let what's the newspaper in
Princeton
great student newspaper there they check
this out for me the building cost a
hundred and twenty nine million dollars
to build for 350 students this was a
decade ago about three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a student meg Whitman
got zillions of dollars and redo her tax
burden was reduced by millions I have
nothing against Meg Whitman I have
nothing against Princeton but so we gave
a lot of benefit to these people if you
were a progressive liberal Democrat I
think the best stand to take today to be
different than the people that are
running is to say I want to help the
poor I want to do away with federal
programs I want to do away with these
programs that are helping the rich the
people to go to Heights school this is
where he teaches I'm really being mean
to you now
any emotions any answers just make fun
of it yeah yeah no I'm sorry I shouldn't
that was beyond the pale I should not
have said that but to people and that's
why I love Hillsdale I really do because
it is got principles but again what
would be the solution to this problem of
I mean is it an education problem we
just need to people need to understand
well there are so there are ideas out
there we're not going to change this
overnight and let's accept that so if
you want to be practical and let's be
politically reasonable for a sin there
are some ideas out there that would
and Nick get at the problem and start to
do something about it do we really need
to give student loans to people who are
in graduate school for their eighth or
ninth year and getting an MBA at Harvard
could we put some limits on the student
loan program that's one approach put
limits on could we say let's make it
clear that people can go to college and
sell equity in themselves rather than
debt in themselves when a person goes to
college and takes out a loan they are in
effect there's an IOU involved here I
owe you the federal government twenty
thousand thirty thousand dollars that's
what it is it's a it's a debt instrument
why don't they issue equity interests in
themselves
why don't they sell stock in themselves
I will give you seven percent of my
earnings for the first five years after
I graduate if you give me fifty thousand
dollars for my college income share
agreements ISAs are called why don't
they're not illegal but there's some
doubt in the law whether they're
enforceable contracts and there are some
who say oh this is indentured servitude
and come up with purple language to
describe them I think they're perfectly
legitimate contractual arrangements so
there are some things we could do that
with wean us away from the student loan
program and involve the private sector
and incidentally get the government out
of the business because this could all
be done
JPMorgan Chase or Bank of America or
anyone could do this rocket not rocket
loans what is it called
anyway Quicken Loans whatever you know
someone could do this in the private
sector so there are alternatives to what
doing and what about the we sort of
touched on it a little with regard to
people who are going for non you know
non higher IDI routes to their careers
and there's a lot of talk about that
about you know coming up with trade
schools and making sure that there's not
this sort of notion that you're not a
real person if you don't get the
four-year degree marker but but what
about their careers afterward problem I
mean that's that's but one of the the we
haven't talked enough about the third
leg of the stool in terms of part of the
higher ed crisis and and what can we do
to better the reporting that you were
talking about me well taking the first
thing is I hate to say this in an
audience of college students and college
graduates but I think there are two
we've over invested in higher IDI
in one sense we put too much money into
traditional four-year degree programs
and too much money into people getting a
diploma for the sake of getting diploma
and the government plays a little role
in this you know President Obama
promised we would have the highest
percentage of graduates you know we were
at slipping behind other nations and
we'll get back to number one there are
foundations out there the Lumina
Foundation from Indianapolis is one and
other foundations who say our goal the
Gates Foundation is to increase the
percentage of Americans with degrees so
there is a push sort of mindless prose
for people to get four-year degrees and
we probably ought to emphasize more
these other alternatives than we have so
that's part of what we ought to be doing
is putting more emphasis on these other
things and I think the federal
government
is as I indicated earlier a large part
of the problem but state governments
have contributed to this too and and
others and well-meaning private people
have contributed to this I don't I think
the government ought to get out of the
higher-end business in a perfect world
but I'll accept the fact that we're
going to have government in the higher
ed business and saying how can we reform
it and one way is to privatize some
parts of it like the lending process to
reduce the advantages of associated with
this sort of 130 million dollar
dormitories and you give them money to a
stadium project you get a tax deduction
for that so you could watch people throw
balls back and forth I mean what's the
public policy of why we substance i's
people throwing balls I have nothing to
gets throwing balls I kind of like to
watch football games
what sort of while basketball games even
more but why do we subsidize this stuff
why it makes zero sense whatsoever and
in my opinion isn't there something on
the sort of moral plain of a kind of a
basic re-education about comfort that
there's sort of like when I think of my
own and I was in a dinosaur environment
that hadn't gotten with the times it was
sleepy and small my undergrad was one of
the last lousy cafeterias and I was
going to school in the 90s and and and
then I went back and visited there later
on as an alum and ended become
unbelievably luxurious just beautiful
with 50 different sort of well our phase
stations and things like that
and it was still nothing compared to
most of the me
streams know that's one of the problems
I mean higher it is there's I called it
once in a Wall Street Journal piece I
wrote the country club is a ssin of
higher ed and there is that I mean
you've got to have I mean we're these
kids are they're they're they're living
in absolute poverty and because there is
we don't have a lazy river at our school
you've got to have a lazy river edge
have to explain what a lazy
Aleya the river is what we used to call
a swimming pool but instead of being a
hundred feet long it's a thousand feet
long and it's and you can rent a little
raft and if it's at a progressive school
that most of these are it has a little
place on the route I've seen some of
these inner tube where there's room for
a cup to put your beer in why you'll go
down the river and contemplate life and
get stoned or drunk or whatever kids do
these days and up why the heck should we
subsidize this kind of stuff so that
there is a lot of that and fancy dorms
and so on that's part of it another
manifestation of the rising cost of
higher it is an area I already mentioned
is administrative bloat and I it's bad
on a cost basis it costs a lot of money
but what's worse is it's crowding out
the academic function of a university
the academic function is getting cut
down graded by people who are
functionaries I think the French might
call them people who are doing things
that have nothing to do with learning
but a lot to do with other things I
mentioned diversity and inclusion is an
example but I could have mentioned even
fundraising as an example where
universities are just overwhelmed with
administrators and and there's a lot of
evidence for this up the road by is the
greatest argue this is a guy up at
Hopkins in Mall
or Ben Ginsberg a great guy
Benjamin Ginsberg he's a professor of
political scientists he'd probably
politically you know a left of Elizabeth
Warren for all I know but he is he says
the universities are being just
destroyed by administrators we no longer
make the decisions we're no longer in
charge and whether the faculty ought to
be in charge is a debatable issue I
don't sure they should be totally in
charge I am not sure I'd buy a used car
from the average faculty member but they
are doing what universities are supposed
to do they're creating and disseminating
knowledge and ideals and virtue virtue
by the way has gone by the wayside
at most schools no you know there are
some exceptions but most schools we
don't care about the work or they've
decided to try a new idea of what virtue
is yeah vigorously trying to train
everyone in virtues that may not
actually be yeah I think virtues that in
the sweep of Western civilization over
the last several thousand years would
not be considered virtues anyway you
know I mean they're being put before we
open up to questions from the audience
and do please if when we do we'll have
microphones for you so just raise your
hand I know calling you at a time I
wanted to sort of ask you to sort of and
this is Washington a lot of people who
actually really care about trying to
make the doable change to sort of touch
off the first snowflakes at the top of
the mountain they could start an
avalanche and actually get something
done in with to solve big problems with
little changes if you had to say if you
were talking to a room of interested
people like this and donors and
politicians and said what are we all
gonna rally around what where do we put
the very tip of the spear and all of our
wait what would you choose
the one thing to push on I know usually
solutions are multivalent you got to do
a lot but if you had to pick one what
would it be and why
well you're gonna be in nasty to me
you're expecting me I'm good at
criticizing people but uh solutions uh
I'm a lowly college professor in
Appalachia you know eking out a bare
existence teaching as I said to begin
with in a practical sense and in a
Washingtonian sense looking at
Washington
I suspect the single most important
thing that we could do would be to work
to downsize and change the student loan
program which would help with the cost
side and the money that those programs
raise through higher tuition fees pay
for all these administrators and lazy
rivers and seventeen million dollar
football coach well they don't pay for
the seventh of football coaches football
coaches by the way pay for themselves at
the really good schools there I'm not
saying they're all virtuous all
contraire but that but but that's what I
would do I would work on getting the
government out of the business of doing
the harm that they do the most and the
most single harm they do is in this area
so can we let it go at that I'll have to
very good so questions yes please thank
you for a fascinating talk I wanted to
ask if this problem that you've outlined
here isn't something that's sort of
common in human affairs it's a lack of
good governance and I'm wondering what
sort of structures academic institutions
could adopt and that would improve that
in this very room of a few weeks ago
there was a presentation about the
problem at Oberlin
and it really sounds outrageous you can
look at the corporate world and look at
the way a corporate board of directors
works but it seems to me that alumni of
people talk about stockholders when you
graduate if you if you become a
shareholder and in the university or so
you have kind of a vested interest in
protecting the reputation of your your
sheepskin or whatever and it seems to me
that there are a lot of ways to approach
this problem do you have any comment on
that well I think University governance
is horrible the way it happens and that
gets to your question boards of trustees
at universities are well I think mostly
well intended people or truly interested
in their college and so forth but they
they're clueless about two-thirds of the
bad things that happen at campus I don't
know the specifics of the Overland
College details but I'm sure that the
Board of Trustees Oberlin College a
large majority of didn't have a clue
what was going on at Gibson's bakery and
in Overland Ohio that has led to
embarrassment to Oberlin tens of
millions of dollars of potential damage
for them hurt the college greatly led to
some absolutely grotesque behavior on
the part of administrators who should
have been frankly just fired and so in
my I don't want to keep trying to sell
my book because both people that read it
have liked it we will be selling books
we will be selling books at a fairly
reasonable price and if you I will leave
an autograph um if you want which I
doubt you will but they there is a
governance issue in higher ed that who
owns the universities who runs the
universities well the faculty think
they'd
they don't usually but they think they
do and it's some schools they have a lot
of power Larry Summers was president of
Harvard University he was secretary the
Treasury is mr. everything he got fired
who fired him the faculty he didn't like
the notion that women were as good at
math as men or something
so that's basis for firing I guess so
the the faculty don't control the
university uh the Alumni think they
control the university they give a lot
of money and some schools they have some
clout but most places they don't know on
the university the administration
probably has more claimed on the
universe who owns the universities no
one knows well theoretically it's the
Board of Trustees or the Board of
Governor and Virginia's the board
visitors who's on the Board of Visitors
some of the governor appoints for a few
years or someone in the case of private
schools that given a lot of money
once the prestige of the name goes to
meeting about four times a year the
president University fills them with
good wine and drinks gives them tickets
to the football games and listens to the
propaganda that they feed the board
which is bears modest or no resemblance
to what's really going on at the school
and this is shameful but you know do I
have an easy solution for it no but I
think that's one area I would start
looking for some solutions it sounds
like you'd want to get into the the ear
of a governor and get them to take yeah
by the way I I spent a year on the
Spelling's Commission on the future of
higher education where I was supposed to
be part of a group of 20 blue-ribbon
group and it really was a blue-ribbon
group of very famous people former
cabinet members governors
president presidency universities
universities like Michigan and MIT and
so forth I was on this really
blue-ribbon group point we were gonna
turn education round what did we do my
wife was right from the day once I've
agreed to be on it she says you're not
gonna do a damn thing she's more or less
right anyway sorry yes there's a
question in the bank there hi I'm one of
the Hillsdale students here on the DC
program and at Hillsdale we really enjoy
John Henry Newman and his work the idea
of a university and in that Newman talks
about how the biggest contribution a
university makes to this student is
teaching him or her how to look at the
world as an integrated whole but also
the mark that the university leaves on
each student and my question for you is
how can we as college degree holders go
out and teach people about this idea and
communicate it because this really does
seem like the promise of higher
education that's been lacking in this
post-industrial kind of postmodern world
it's an excellent question I missed a
little bit of the part of it but I've
read now Cardinal a now st. Newman he's
been promoted to a saint
it's one of the few areas of life where
you can die and a hundred years later
get promoted the Pope recently made a
John Henry Newman a saint one of the
greatest wonderful pieces of things ever
written
I wish every student read it and I wish
every member of Board of Trustees would
read it we don't we've lost sight of the
big things in life and the important
things alike oK we've lost sight I
mentioned just through the word virtue
out is just as a sort of a shorthand
version of talking about sort of the non
practical non-vocational dimensions of
higher education we've lost sight of
them but you know I think our nation has
lost sight of a lot of the things that
used to be the glue that brought us
together as a nation I'm getting a
little way from your question but the
glue that makes us Americans is that we
all have some common thing that we hold
in common that we that we believe in
that we believe dear to us we're losing
that first of all kids aren't even
taking classes in history anymore at
most schools they don't know about the
founding fathers and I think that
chamber we need to move back to a core
curriculum like Hillsdale is done
there's a group of us wild-eyed
reformers who trying to remind the
liberal arts colleges and in higher ed
of their own tradition like to
mistranslate or retranslate our tastes
liberalize the where that phrase liberal
arts came from as the arts of Liberty
just to kind of shake it up like you're
actually part of what you're trying to
teach is self-government and that's an
interior thing and an exterior political
thing and that's I think been lost
one more question I think we have time
for one more question yes oh no my pink
shirt over there or the blue jacket so I
work at university Catholic you and all
the things you said her her true see me
where are you Catholic you sorry what
you know that Catholic University up the
road three miles you can see you can see
the dome the shrine from here I was
reading about endowments the other day
you know the history having apparently
go back to Greece there's minute there's
the Carolingian Renaissance there's
other Nobles I'm in France that the
state they're the state the nobles the
government subsidized education so it
seemed to me excusing me to be a part of
the kingly power right of a nation it
seems to be a human nature thing but you
say we can do it better and you to fund
it and down what's our different than
and what is your thinking about cuz
there's already so much money that we've
been hanging on Yale
but uh there's many endowments mini-mini
I was googling the other day there's so
much what is your thinking about I mean
there's all that money there that seemed
you always get news oh yay Liz buying
land in California with their endowment
to change the world yeah yeah so sorry
it was long well I I did a piece I I did
some serious empirical work on in Dallas
first of all Adam Smith had it right in
the wealth of nations when he noted that
the professors at Oxford University no
longer teach anything anymore because
the students are now because a pre in an
earlier period the faculty got paid by
the students directly and when that
stopped the faculty didn't give a damn
about the students anymore and the world
went to hell which probably a slight
exaggeration but there's an element of
truth and what happened is endowments
insulate us from having to pay any
attention to achieving excellence why
should we the money's coming in anyway
and an endowment money by the way mostly
does not support lowering costs to
students i I've done it empirical work
on there's a run regression less
economist we run regression equation I
run tons of regression equations on this
the money doesn't go to support students
it does go to teach lower teaching load
for us faculty it does go to increase
salaries it does grow to do a lot of
things that really I don't think justify
contribution in college and this is a
terrible thing to say here cuz I give
money of college is I think colleges are
worthwhile in endeavors I love my cult
my alma mater I love the school I teach
that I love Hillsdale but some people
have abused that dimension of it as well
so I'm not against endowments if I were
they will not broadcast this to the rest
of the world because Larry aren't who
runs
Hillsdale and laws endowments and he
should he should but in any case
endowments are an issue that need to be
addressed
well there is an issue what should be
done with endowments what the question
was why aren't they forced to use them
to to lower at cost well that that is a
good empirical question I will say that
when they put in endowment tax in on
very very large endowments I testified
before the House Ways and Means
Committee over down the road here before
the gang of 535 and I said there's a
case for it and I usually don't promote
higher taxes on anything but a tax on
I'll say Harvard to our young lady in
the fourth roll is already suffering
enough ah a tax on Harvard would
probably wouldn't hurt the world and
might help it a little bit well with
that please join me in thanking thank
you
[Applause]